[Music]
welcome back to Hannity so in her new
book
what happened Hillary Clinton takes
shots at all the people she blamed for
her embarrassing 2016 presidential
election loss including the former FBI
director James Comey who I argue had to
fix it listen to this four months after
the election I tried to put it all out
of my mind
it would do me no good to brood over my
mistake and it wasn't healthy or
productive to dwell on the ways I felt
I'd been shipped by then FBI director
Jim Comey three times over the final
five months of the campaign here the
reaction from the American Center for
Law and Justice the chief counsel and
also the president's attorney Jay
Sekulow and Fox News anchor attorney
Greg Jarrett all right Jay I'm going to
start with you tonight we have the issue
of the Records Act we also have the
issue of 18 USC I believe 793 correct me
if I'm wrong what about the Hatch Act
because I'm getting all these rumblings
the commis and you know in real legal
trouble down any truth to that so so
here's what we're hearing on the Hatch
Act so that's an internal if you're a
government employee there are
prohibitions on engaging in political
campaigns so what happened was there was
a report from the Office of Special
Counsel not to be confused with robert
muller this is the Office of Special
Counsel inside the Department of Justice
that was investigating or is
investigating James commis activity for
exactly what you just said just moments
ago this kind of intervention in the
campaign last year and that could
include being barred for up to five
years from Federal service include
include fines and penalties but it
points to something deeper there's also
an inspector general's investigation
going on right now as to James Comey as
well in addition to that you've got
Senator Graham saying last week he
smelled a rat in the fact that the
declination letter and that's what it
was regarding the whole Hillary Clinton
email situation was written at least two
maybe three months before they
interviewed 16 witnesses including the
target so he had already been
transferring around this declination
letter so that all of this together to
me points to the fact that there must be
there has to be
an investigation of James Comey going on
and it should be at multiple levels and
I've got to believe now this is going to
happen and I also think Greg that the
door has been open in a lot of ways
because the fix was in
that means the Attorney General now can
begin his own vesting investigation anew
we know she violated the law you know we
also know the leakers of violating laws
we know here Jay saying call me
potentially violated laws debbie
Wasserman Schultz is in trouble uranium
one is a big issue right and what's
frustrating is there's no evidence on
Russia but none of these things get
investigated and if we're going to have
equal justice under the law in this
country doesn't that have to happen it
absolutely has to happen and look it has
to begin by looking closely at James
Comey who appears to have testified
falsely under oath when he was asked by
the House Judiciary Committee did you
determine not to prosecute Hillary
Clinton before or after you interviewed
her and he said afterwards well it's now
emerged that he wrote a statement of
exoneration of Clinton two months before
he interviewed her and top aides so that
would appear to be false testimony by
Comey and it would also appear that his
entire investigation of Hillary Clinton
was nothing more than a charade it's a
charade and it's a sham and in light you
know I honestly think Jay we're the only
ones that point out the specific laws
that she broke we know mishandling of
classified information happened we know
obstruction nobody gets to delete emails
bleach use bleach pit and acid wash and
then destroy BlackBerry's and iPhones if
any of us did that we be in trouble we
would be asking both of you to come to
jail and visit me we would well we would
do more than that we'd represent you but
in addition to that let me let me say
something else here
you know when James Comey got on his
made a statement about how he was just
shocked and appalled at what had
happened with President that former
President Clinton and then the Attorney
General Loretta Lynch on that tarmac and
he had to take action
he bypassed the entire entire internal
operating procedures within the
Department of Justice
he himself took on the role as Attorney
General now granted Loretta Lynch was
severely compromised in this without
question but there was still a Deputy
Attorney General there was a process to
go forward with here's what you have
James Comey thinks he is above the law
he thinks he's above the rules and
regulation and in a sense James Comey is
creating his own own really
constitutional crisis here because
you've got this idea that there are
policies procedures rules and guidelines
and he ignores them and can run away
with with impunity that's not the way
it's supposed to be so what I want to
know is where is this scope as it
relates to the Trump Russia collusion no
evidence story dana rohrabacher meets
with Julian Assange Greg Julian Assange
the one guy that knows where the
information came from the DNC her emails
etc he doesn't want to talk to them and
they keep expanding out the
investigation in that sense this is
there's something radically wrong and
then add Comey getting his best friend
on purpose by leaking to the New York
Times right and the other point you made
earlier Sean is what about the 30,000
destroyed emails Congress had issued a
subpoena to preserve 33,000 destroyed
emails Congress had issued a subpoena
lawful subpoena to preserve and produce
all of her emails instead she destroyed
30,000 of them and there's no way to
prove the content of them because she
cleaned the server destroying any
incriminating evidence but destruction
of evidence by itself regardless of
whether those documents exist she admits
she destroyed 30,000 that by itself is
obstruction of justice it is beyond me
how she has not as yet then held for an
indictment on that count alone well let
me just have one thing really quick shot
I'm holding in my hand three Freedom of
Information Act requests that we just
sent out on this whole matter of the
declination letter about being written
three months two to three months before
the interviews took place look there is
no justification for prejudging this
case or any other case before the May
witnesses are interviewed by the way
including people on her staff that were
also allowed to be serving as her lawyer
I mean this is unprecedented what Cheryl
modulator who ever absorbed a suspect
right there long before the witnesses
are even interviewed no prep possible
outrageous it's unbelievable all right
guys thank you both for being with us
when we come back